hello everybody
it's so good to see you
oh man i'm so happy to see all your
faces everybody's here it's exciting god
you were a goddamn mess the last time i
saw you buddy you were just you're
puffy-faced and uh and but mostly you
actually didn't look that bad you mostly
which i'm just not used to not that i've
never seen you like that
but like you're not usually that sort of
i don't know self-conscious is that the
right way yeah self-conscious like about
about the way you look i i feel like for
the most part you look exactly the same
except your life is worse yeah your
lighting was worse and also you were
just rubbing your eyes a lot maybe you
were a little tired like a morning tired
but that's you know a little puffy your
face your face was the same face
i do i do have the same face yes yeah
week to week doesn't change that much
year to year sometimes it changes
oh yeah
year to year it changes for sure yeah
yeah no i yeah i was uh
yeah i don't know i was feel i i i was
just off a jet
remember i was and i was complaining
about that and i was just feeling a
little off i think
but um you know we all have our our bad
days and
and i appreciated all the support and i
i've been getting a lot of support from
people um
what people what what do you mean like
people have been coming on and telling
you hey robbie
it was an interesting response that i
saw um
on social media just about people uh i
don't know i think i think that they
they they were they were saying it was
okay it was okay to have a down day hey
man it's okay i get tired too sometimes
you get tired i get tired man you guys
get tired of her
all i ever am is tired
if i had some nose clams at the time if
i had like just like one bag of no slime
nose clams and do you okay so now we're
talking about the gang gets wack part
two
and i was watching it last night with my
beloved spouse oh by the way i'm just
gonna throw this out there in terms of
staying current caitlyn broke her foot
okay
i saw yeah her instagram thing i was
like did you break your foot and she
said the doctor said it wasn't
officially a break it might have been a
sprain but it feels like it's broken
well she's walking around in a boot and
um yeah good ass
this is this is the sixth
sixth bone that she's broken since how'd
she do it this time did she put her shoe
on or did she yeah
god she breaks easily but she never gets
sick it's such a weird thing right it is
crazy she has not little is all
happening she has not gotten sick in
years i haven't i think i would trade
i think i would still take
getting sick over breaking that many
bones oh yeah right like
if someone said hey you could never get
sick for years and years like not a head
cold nothing but you're gonna break a
bone like every six months
i'd be like nah i'll take the cold
i think agree agree i mean what kind of
sick are we talking about if we're
talking about a cold shirt what kind of
yeah sure yeah you're going to get lupus
every month i mean
no she uh she's broken her foot and
she's hobbling around like a jerk but
she's she's a trooper and she'll get
through it like she's gotten through the
last 20 bronze phones that she's no were
you there when she when she bro when she
broke it
no
uh did you hear the screams
no no i just i
i just saw her uh walking out to the
backyard and she was limping
and i just shook my head as she
approached and i said you broke your
foot and didn't you and she said yes
i just knew the look
i knew the look and i already have i
have a whole section of the closet
of a closet that we have in the house
called the caitlyn section and it's it
has boots full boots um
those uh like leg cast boots
a cane and two sets of crutches and we
just keep them
we just keep them we just keep them
around
because we might need them again and and
in fact
why don't you just set up you've got to
feel like you have enough room in your
house to just set aside a whole room
that's just for triage
you know what i mean like
just a just an emergency room with your
own little vr
yeah your own little er you know you
have like a a guy that's on call and
when he shows up you know he's got his
little doctor bag but you you've already
got it all set up for her you know to
get you've got an x-ray machine in there
you've got you know whatever equipment
that he would need so she doesn't have
to you know ghost hobble
invest in some sort of bubble boy suit
you know
some sort of like just bubble wrap kind
of thing
yeah she could bubble wrap caitlyn every
single morning before she leaves the
house yeah yeah
you know really keep her safe
you promised me i'm sure when when you
got married you probably promised to
keep her safe and
all that kind of stuff so yeah i think
it makes sense with cars sometimes i'm
like why are cars not like just giant
round rubber balls
you know like
like why didn't we do that so like it's
like sorry i ran into you good thing we
just bounced off each other
you know
the way your brain works is amazing
i want to see that i want to see that
what about a man on a musical you can't
make a car big round
safe rubber ball i don't know yeah it's
like you're sitting you're sitting in in
in the middle of the ball and the ball
rotates around you but it's clear so you
can see out
you know you can see 360 degrees i think
it's a great idea um
you have all that stuff but there's so
much rubber
safe foamy soft rubber around everything
that you know if when you slam into
someone it's just a nice good bounce you
know bounce around but but but wouldn't
that bounce you with such force that it
would break your neck
no because it's it's just rubber on
rubber it's a good sort of you know you
have a seat belt and you have an airbag
but uh you don't have all those hard
angles and metal and glass everywhere i
don't know what the windshield is but
like you probably
probably have a you know something
something well something that you wrap
around your neck so that your neck can't
really you know so when you do bounce
around you're just like bouncing around
like this
yeah but if it was rubber hitting rubber
you're on the 405
and you smash into somebody
you you're you're it's going to
shoot you to pacoma
you're going to be airborne yeah
things along the way and everyone will
be fine that's right it'll just be an
earth full of full of those like rubber
bouncing balls that you have like two
lacrosse balls or whatever i don't know
some kind of like you know massage ball
and you shoot it at full speed at one
another they're gonna the balls are
gonna be fine yeah they're gonna shoot
everywhere but the balls will be fine
and stuff inside the balls would be fine
you end up in pocoyma so be it you know
what i mean you're you're like you're
like
the first time i've ever been been in
coyman let me grab a bite to eat and
then i'll just bounce right back to
where i would rather be in hell in
caitlyn's triage room
the gang gets waxed it's funny it's it's
wild
it's both it's so funny it's so cartoony
but it's uh it's very funny
do you remember
the thing that popped out
to me the most was
do you remember why we made it so that
we're not
nobody is snorting the cocaine everybody
is rubbing it on their gums
no
no is that a standards and practice
thing that was a standards and practices
thing they told us that we could not
actually see somebody snorting a line of
cocaine
in the episode which is odd on that
effects
on fps
tv has changed man tv has changed yeah
yeah so so we had we pivoted we pivoted
to the gums which is so much funnier
anyway
yeah every time they give us something
like that uh i feel like whatever we
come up with is 10 times funnier than
what we originally intended anyway
yeah because then they're not they don't
have the intent of getting high and it
sort of starts happening accidentally
which is a funnier
sort of engine for story than just like
they want to get high
people online were interested in knowing
do you guys remember what that was that
you were eating charlie the cocaine was
it was it um powdered sugar
flour i think it was like probably just
mounds of flour ew really gluten
yeah
it's a lot of gluten it's probably worse
than cocaine
[Laughter]
we shot that we shot a lot of the
episode in philadelphia in fact in um in
kensington we shot a lot of the episode
in kensington
and caitlyn remembers it being one of
the hottest days she's ever felt on the
planet earth oh i remember it being
really hot cricket thinking those trash
cans are cattle drums is like one of my
favorite things so great for the whole
season
in that scene you guys are walking up to
cricket and sh she said she's wearing a
pair of jeans she said she said that
they had to cut the jeans off of her
they couldn't pull them off of her
the the sweat combined with the
tightness of the jeans
yes yeah she couldn't she couldn't get
them off and they were like pulling them
and pulling them and pulling them
finally wardrobe just came in and cut
them off like she was like it was triage
like she was
maybe she had broken something i don't
know
do you think they had those those kind
of those those like scissors where the
like the the one that touches your skin
is like you know like nice and uh
do you think they actually i do think
the wardrobe department has those yeah
in case they need to cut
performers clothes off of them
because they have sealed them with sweat
i'm a big fan of that the ass play
conversation with danny he's getting out
of his chalice like i never ordered any
ass play
and the woman sitting at the counter
is amazing the thing that jumps out at
me most in watching this episode is how
all of us all of us
are doing
gymnastics like trying to be
just really because we're actors and
we're trying to be funny in each scene
and we're just doing anything and
everything we can to milk every single
moment and we're working so hard and it
works and it's funny but it took a lot
of effort
and danny just
walks onto the screen and is so casual
and he doesn't look like he's doing
anything because he's barely he barely
is and he's so [ __ ] funny he's just
taken us all to school
he's so funny
he's pretty amazing i mean yeah the ass
play conversation
and then the scene where where we're
playing was it two of hearts
oh yeah yes
susie q
it's pretty great
and the um
when you when he shows uh dennis the ad
the body work
by dennis yeah oh and then that was
based on real those were real it says no
rules it says right here no rules it
says no rules now wasn't that photo
just a still shot from you taking your
shirt off for margaret mcpoyle in the
hostage episode like we basically just
screamed
so we create that in the editing room or
do we have that on set or someone just
like
made it no no no no we had that we had
that in the paper yeah yeah it was in
the paper that was the prop the prop uh
they took a picture from me being all
sweaty and and shirtless and uh yeah
just put it this is how old this
television show is that that was based
on real ads that we would see in
newspapers weekly newspapers or or even
the la times where you'd get to the
classified section and then there would
be a
a whole area that would say
massage and body work body work really
so if you specialized in body work you
could call
ramon you could call
jimmy you could call carla
you could call tatiana and they'll show
up and they'll work your body
no problem if you call like who's
showing up if you call one of those
numbers
somebody
scary and then somebody somebody is
somebody somebody somebody's really
scary comes in first and introduces you
to the person yeah yeah somebody really
scary shows up and says you know you'll
be working with tasiana but i need to
have a little conversation with you
first
yeah you know she's going to work your
body she's going to work your body don't
worry about that but bodywork will be
done
um
but um
a different kind of bodywork is going to
occur if uh if yeah we're not satisfied
i don't get it actually if i'm not
satisfied financially yeah yeah i'm
gonna be satisfied we're gonna work and
i'm gonna be satisfied you don't you
need to work your body butt let's put it
that way
you'll be satisfied and i'll be
satisfied there's only one person that
won't be satisfied in this equation then
that's tatiana that's tatiana but we're
not you know let's not concern ourselves
with that let's not concentrate if you
were concerned about that you never
would have made that phone call to begin
with
we're
we're both a part of the same hypocrisy
sir now get in the room
getting all philosophical
don't give me that look sir
you're just as much a part of this as i
am that is kind of what's happening in
the episode where he
we got you said frank gets all pissed
off because we got dennis thinking for
himself again
yeah yeah well that was that was part of
the fun of of creating that episode was
like very like sort of accelerating the
process of of grooming you know and and
getting someone to uh
completely submit to your will
by just totally manipulating them um
what
i like that you made no effort to not
burp directly
no effort just a quick second of just
coming back
no effort what i got put on here i got
to put on airs for you guys i got to put
on edges because we're talking on the
internet
just cause millions of people are gonna
watch this i gotta put on airs
i love the addition of
um the line so you say uh
no no no ass play on this one
and he says well you
no you don't have to do anything with
the ass what the last one it got weird
and he says don't worry about it and you
said well we might have to go go to the
hospital
just think just to be safe
what does that mean i mean what's the
implication i don't know but now there
could be something in there or something
might have torn sure it's just just to
be safe
and then instantly you know exactly
what's going to happen in the next scene
when he says he's laying there reading
the magazine and i never said he's never
ordered any ass playing
he'll he'll do anything with the ass
just the term ass play is really really
funny
yeah
yeah like that's that's
yeah just what she's doing
yeah what's she doing
what kind of play is it
well she you know she's having a look
around exploring a little bit as my
guess you know what i mean uh i don't
know if she's pleasuring herself or me
but either way it's pleasurable for her
uh just but you're the one doing the
work you're the you're doing the body
work
it's it's body work by dennis so yeah
but he's also providing a body um
to be aware of the work that's part of
the providing a body to work with i'm
i'm doing body work yeah yeah i'll do
some body work but i'll provide a body
for you to work
and play but that's the fun of it is
that you're both working you're both
working and playing at the same time
yeah let's not forget that this is
supposed to be fun
you know
honestly ass play is better than ass
work
yeah it seems like there's some more
heavy lifting involved
heavy lifting wow you don't want it to
be worked you want it to be play yeah
you want it to be play yeah ass work
sounds like um you know someone's gonna
get some pleasure out of it for sure but
uh
yeah you're going to be burning a lot
more calories
i have a fun memory of my uh
grandmother coming to set you know
because she lived in philly and um
we were shooting the scene where we find
cricket on the street and he's homeless
and she found it very amusing that he
was a playing a priest and uh
but also just being like so he's uh
we're on cocaine grandma
just trying to like explain it
yeah yeah sitting there with the
earphones like listening to the scene
and just
but she enjoyed it
yeah and then uh
two seasons later we put her in an
episode as one of the red hat ladies
she's sitting with me playing the piano
uh and then she passed away shortly
after that i mean she was like 96 or
something but
um
she would continue to get
checks for the performance because it
would air and you know like little five
dollar
residual checks and i remember my aunt
being like can you cancel these because
it's like a pain for us to like
it's like we we can't process it and
there's a whole thing i don't know
yeah just a stack of checks that only
amount to about like 98 bucks
total yeah if you're lucky yeah we've
talked about the stack of checks right
the stuff we've talked about charlie's
stacking my stack
not on the podcast i don't think so
okay yeah all right let's get into that
just because you brought up a stack of
checks and it's yeah it's the same
thought
unbelievable yeah i don't know i hear
the word stack of checks and then i hear
that it's like a pain in the ass and i
remember
charlie lived in this real [ __ ]
apartment um that we shot the original
sunny in but we loved it we would spend
a lot of time over there and i was so
psyched on the department coming from
new york city i was like we have
a little balcony that we can spoke on
and like yeah
yeah
uh so um i was so broke and glenn was
not he was never broke he was always
working but yeah
i was yeah i was always successful yeah
go ahead yes you've been successful from
the day you graduated from the juilliard
school glenn and i
started working and getting close to me
the second we tried to be an actor but
go ahead
it's all true you are struggling which
makes sense oh god that's just
struggling
struggling in so many ways and um
emotionally uh as well when i would walk
into your apartment and i would see this
i saw a stack of checks and i'm not
exaggerating glenn like this thing i
remember
yeah
i just for some reason i remember them
always be like in my memory they were
sitting on top of this keyboard they
were like
always on the keyboard
i had a keyboard and a bed and that was
probably about it that was it and a pile
of jacks
and and empty yoohoo containers
everywhere because that's all i mean
yeah
that's
would just drink yoo-hoo all day
and eat macaroni and cheese and smoke
cigarettes i mean that's the best part
the man like the streets early 20s
so i look at this this stack of checks
yeah and i'm like can i look at this and
you're like yeah sure and i'm looking at
them and they're
they're these payments hundreds of
thousands of dollars right like no i
mean no no no no no not that much but
like but but even maybe hundreds like
four or five grand sitting around right
there yes it would be like a check for
three hundred dollars a check for sex
six hundred dollars a check for
50 cents a check for 75 cents a check
for two grand
and i'm looking at them and i ask them
have you cashed these and he says no
that's why they're just sitting there
how long have you had them i don't know
they just keep coming and i just it's
such a pain in the ass
and i say yes
well you've got to turn them over you
have to sign them
that was what you had to do you had to
sign it and then you had to walk it to
the bank and then in exchange for that
for all that work the bank would give
you money it would give you cash for the
checks
well that's not what it was was that i
didn't want to walk down to wells fargo
every time i got a
seven dollar check i waited for like a
month and i collected all the checks
from the month and i brought them all
down and i i put them all i didn't cash
them i didn't walk around with a
briefcase full of money i had a what
they call a bank account yeah and i put
them into the bank account but yeah i
mean that was the independent film
channel that thing
was a cash cow man
i mean yeah but for a guy like that's
for goddamn sure for now
well he's going to say for a guy in
roberto
and then i would i would record those at
buzzies and i went down to buzzies that
one day and there was someone else in
there recording
and they had fired me but they'd
forgotten to tell and they'd like double
booked and i went down they're like oh
yeah yeah we replaced they were trying
to replace me for like three years and
they just couldn't do it
but
it was a good thing why would they why
would they replace the person that's
never cashing your checks i mean they're
just basically paying you they're not
even paying them for free this guy's
working for free doesn't even know it i
can't by the way if you give him yoohoo
he'll he's happy to just give him a
yoo-hoo and a bag of funyuns
well the whole thing with that was that
i was like i i bought a house i'd like
to i put a down payment on a house that
i couldn't afford
with the money that i had saved up from
the luis guzman show and the ifc money
and i and i was like okay i think i can
swing this and the day that i like
bought that house was the day i got
fired from that ifc job but like the
next week we sold sunny so
it all worked out i thought i was gonna
have to like rent the whole place out
your life worked out what can i say
stepping [ __ ] left and right everywhere
you go people just want to hire you no
no you don't step in [ __ ] but you're
just that's that shows you struggling
first
yes
not a whole lot
why didn't you just hire rob to forge
your signature on the checks and walk
them to the bank for you and give him
just like a cut of yeah
that would have been a good job for him
let's make one thing clear there was no
issue here i just was saving them up and
then i would go once a month with all my
checks this was this was a sensible
practice
100 no but for a very for a very broken
man as rob was it was
um it was like you would have been
living paycheck to page
literally
wait what
so how's him being broke my fault
[Laughter]
by the way speaking of cuts i have to
say i love charlie that moment when you
see cricket on the street and you're
talking to him and then you say he can
stay at dee's place and then you reach
into his little um cup and take a few
coins out
okay
[Music]
guys guys guys guys guys it's not cheap
to produce these things you know
yeah i mean look at the lighting kits we
have to afford yeah and then i like to
let the sun wash me out but then i you
know that's not reliable because i don't
know whether the sun's gonna be shining
you know so it's tricky yeah yeah and we
can talk about how you guys are
constantly struggling to find good
lighting and how i've never had a single
issue later but uh first i'd like to
shout out to our friends at uh viori who
are helping us pay for those light kits
you know if you aren't familiar with
viora you should be because they make
the most comfortable workout slash
lounging apparel on the planet it's a
new perspective on performance apparel
are you guys sick and tired of
traditional workout gear mm-hmm oh yeah
it's been just pissing me off traditions
okay well look that you know the first
thing is to realize that you're you're
not alone oh good i thought i was the
only one on the planet who was concerned
about no no no actually uh many more
people than you you would think are sick
and tired of their traditional workout
gear but viori has the shorts the
leggings and joggers for us i mean
everything is designed to work out in
but it doesn't it doesn't look or feel
like it
now these shorts are so comfortable you
you will want to wear them all the time
whether you're sweating or not and they
look great too which of course is 90 of
the appeal of wearing anything because
we're all vain
yeah but they are made to work out in so
that you can look great when you're not
wearing anything too you know which is
90 of the appeal of exercising right
so all together we're talking like 180
appealing you know that's that's pretty
good that's a lot of appeal and viori is
offsetting 100
of its carbon footprint
yeah yeah that's another great
percentage 100.
uh do you really need any more reason
here i mean viori is an investment in
your happiness for our listeners they
are offering 20 off your first purchase
so get yourself
some of the most comfortable and
versatile clothing on the planet at
viori.com
sunnypod that's v
u
o r i dot com slash
sunny pod and not only will you receive
20 off your first purchase but enjoy
free shipping
on any u.s orders over 75 dollars and
free returns go to viori.com
sunnypod and discover the versatility of
yori clothing
[Applause]
you know what rob i had a funny thing i
i i decided i don't know why i was
i listened to a screenwriting lecture
um
by paul schrader and then i got flooded
with memories of that time where i had a
pile of checks and on a keyboard and we
were making a
home movie that turned into change our
lives but
i remember that you had been working
with paul schrader on script or
something or like was he guiding you on
i don't know how to write
the first script that i wrote and we i
wound up optioning it to a company
called propaganda films and then
propaganda they optioned it for no joke
i think it was a thousand dollars which
was so much money
but after taxes and commission i
couldn't stop you know working at the
restaurant and then paul
schrader signed on to direct it
so he and i were working together
on a draft
of this movie that that that i wrote
that he was going to make
and then
then the company went bankrupt it was
called those invited in
oh right
that's a good title keep going let's
keep talking
it was not funny it was not funny it was
a it was a drama like super dark drama
the kind of movie that paul schrader
would make for the audience paul
schrader uh wrote taxi driver and raging
bull
and directed some really amazing movies
but
he's uh he's quite a character and the
whole thing fell apart and just and that
was a huge impetus
for me to never want to go through that
process again where in the end i had a
draft that i didn't really love because
paul wanted to take in directions that i
wasn't into but i was just listening to
him
um
and i
thought well if if he wants to go in
this direction then i should write that
and then at the end of the year he the
movie fell apart he went on to direct a
movie called autofocus
and then something else good movie i had
a thousand dollars that i had made from
it for a year
and i thought i'd never want to do that
again ever so when we so when i when i
wrote the original original sunny and
brought it to you guys
the thought was always to make it
ourselves so that we didn't have to do
that again
i mean i was in a similar place from you
know doing
testing constantly for tv shows and
never getting the parts and finally
getting the louis guzman show and then
you know seeing that kind of go over a
cliff and feeling like i could do so
much give me an opportunity to do more
and then
just kind of being like i don't want to
i still kind of feel this way where
you know i hope the phone rings and
sometimes it rings with something
interesting but
most of what i read i'm like
i i don't know let's just do our own
thing
but every now and then you read
something great there are other
brilliant people out there just
if you can't wait for them to you can't
wait forever for them to call because
most of the time they don't
yeah and there's there's no there's
there's also no no replacing working
with your friends provided your friends
are talented i mean
there's nothing better than that i mean
that was the thing that excited me from
the very beginning about all this was
was stop it rob i see you yes i'm
burping god damn it i mean you you held
back two burps and then you just finally
just fun release why don't you let me
just burp right now get your burps
out it's only when i start talk it's
only when i start talking that's what
then i start
it's the jinx you've got have you
murdered someone
the birthing
the burping
no
no
no i have never no i have not murdered
someone
um
[Music]
you can't murder canadians
[Laughter]
for the listeners out there
glenn's going through a crisis of
conscience right now because
i don't know let's listen he's doing a
bit but he hasn't fully committed to it
like i can tell that you kind of are
like oh do i want to do this
do i want to do this
you know what i mean i see it i see
what's going on you're like kind of like
oh do i do a i've murdered people a
bitter
then then your mind was like i'm kind of
tired of it and maybe it's in
hundred percent that is so accurate
that's that's so perceptible completely
accurate it's completely yeah that's
that's exactly the thought process
rewind it for the creeps and and even if
the listeners should go back and watch
this on the creep channels because you
you can see exactly what charlie just
explained
he won
he was going for it but then didn't but
then but then stopped
no
no
no i have never
no i have not murdered someone
um
you bailed on the bit which is totally
within your rights uh what were we just
talking about that we were talking about
uh
well making stuff with your friends and
your family making stuff oh that's what
it was yeah yeah no i i mean that was
what excited me the most the most from
the very beginning was just the the
thought of like getting to make
something i never made anything i'd only
ever
you know been a pawn in somebody else's
game
uh you know whether it be uh tennessee
williams or uh
bill shakespeare
you know bill shakespeare or uh you know
any one of those uh
playwrights
uh david rabe
dave mamet you know what have you
um
and i just thought uh
well you know what it also was it was
coming off of it was coming off of that
80s show and not being fully satisfied
and part of part of that was my fault
because i was i was um too
deferential you know i think it was
deferential to a fault i felt like you
know this is i don't really know what
i'm doing and everybody here knows what
they're doing i had comedic instincts i
had instincts about the scripts i had
instincts about how i felt like it
should be executed
but i thought to myself
what the hell do i know i don't know
[ __ ] you know these guys have been
making that 70s show they've been making
all these
you know great things for years so they
clearly understand you know how to how
to do it and
you know also you're a young guy you're
coming into a network show which is a
big machine right like us our show was
not a big machine it was lean and mean
and just us figuring out as we went
along like there's that feeling of like
whoa man these they're putting some
money in this and who am i to say how to
do it you know when you're starting out
there also no one's gonna [ __ ] listen
to you because you're like you're just
the actor you know
yeah i mean i just uh i look i have a
very specific memory um this is a real
turning point for me uh when we were
rehearsing for an episode of and and you
know for for those folks out there that
don't know how like so with a multi-cam
which a multi-cam is generally i think
defined by there's multiple cameras
shooting at the same time usually in
front of a live studio audience or it's
at least
portrayed to be that way
um and that 80s show was a fox live or a
yeah like a live multi-cam show so you'd
rehearse for a week and then you'd do
the show live anyway we were in
rehearsals and we were rehearsing a
scene that i thought was really really
funny i thought it was really well
written and i was enjoying it and you
know but i was coming from theater so i
wasn't
i i would my process like i was a little
slower to make
strong choices right i was like we've
got a week to rehearse this so like
let's rev up into it you know let's i'll
figure it out as we go and then i'll be
ready you know when it's when it's game
time you know we were doing this scene
and it just wasn't it wasn't fully
working you know but i knew there was a
way to make it work um but you know the
director just kind of jumped to like
this he was like you know this this
scenes it's just not working uh it's
it's not working we should just uh cut
it or rewrite it or whatever and i was
like well
and i finally did speak up i was like
hold on a second i actually do think
it's i think it's funny i think we just
need to
rehearse it which is what we're here to
do
to like try to figure out how to make it
as funny as possible you know he was
like no it's just not working and you
know and i remember in my mind thinking
this [ __ ] guy doesn't get what's
funny he doesn't know what's funny he
doesn't get he did he thinks it's not
funny because he doesn't get it but that
doesn't mean it's not funny and i was
like
i was like can you just i was like hold
on can we just i have an idea can i just
try something
and i distinctly remember the director
sitting like this
and you know and and i could see his
thought process his thought process was
was this is a waste of my time why is
this [ __ ] kid
trying to tell me how to do my job
but he's the lead of the show so i have
to just let him do what he wants so he
was like uh yeah okay
action and then just like looking at his
watch like
you know which of course sapped uh
sapped all my confidence and so you know
whatever it was that i was planning to
do i just completely blew it because i
had no confidence and then
from that point forward it was really a
little like like something's not sitting
well with me here that this this doesn't
feel right so
you know um
it was moments like that that made me
realize i had strong opinions about how
how things should be executed
and so when we started making this it
was it was it was an opportunity to test
to test that i think that machinery is
what goes so wrong in so many tv shows
certainly of that era too where like
it's the the way it's done is locked
down and the power dynamics are so
locked in and
you know there's
i've been around you know those sort of
multicams too where the writers are are
one camp and they're like we're the
writers and and these actors don't get
it and the studio doesn't get it and
it's just like if if everyone's not
working together
to make this thing as best as it can it
just sort of falls apart yeah totally if
an actor comes in to our show
and says funnier [ __ ] than we've put in
the script
great
and the best idea has got to win like
this
but there's still an integrative process
there has to be but there's a curator
there right who's deeming whether
something's funny or i'm sure there have
been
actors on our show
over the years who've come in and truly
thought that what they were saying is
funnier than what we wrote that's
happened before um even we've done
versions of that before where we've
written something and then
maybe i've said the line differently and
i thought oh that's that's making this
particular moment better and then
charlie's like no it's not and then i
ask you and you say no no it's better on
the page and then you go oh okay i trust
the i trust the curation process but
there's got to be
because otherwise it's just everybody's
sort of
communicating it can't be a free-for-all
it can't be it can't be a free-for-all
yeah and there are there are those other
dynamics that go on too which is
somebody is protecting
they're protecting their position and if
i'm the writer and that's what i do and
that's what i bring to the party and
you're changing that then then that is
uh that that is something to me that
that's potentially damaging what did you
guys do uh one season of that
we did yeah yeah yeah i think we did 13
episodes of it um
i had a great time i i really enjoyed it
it was extremely formative i needed to
do that before we i could have ever done
uh it's always sunny i needed to get
that out of my system i think
i remember you had a we may have
discussed this in the podcast but maybe
not but glenn you had a pilot
offer
you had a pilot offer so we had we had
made sonny and we weren't sure if we
were going to we we wanted to go make it
but you had this
real world offer in front of you and you
were you were trying to figure out
whether or not you were going to take it
or test for the show i do remember there
was there was one sitcom that i tested
for
or gone in for that they they really
liked me for and uh
you know this is back in the day when
i think you guys know that i used to do
this but
um before auditions like if it was
something where i wasn't
like you know auditioning is hard and
you're a little self-conscious and and
i mean this is a real
it's a it's a dangerous habit to get
into but it worked for me especially
with comedy with comedy in particular i
was like i need to be able to go in
there and be loose and free so why would
what i would often do is i would
i would show up with my you know thermos
of coffee and maybe have like one shot
of whiskey mixed in there you know but
then i realized i'm like well now i got
to drink the whole coffee to get the
shot so that doesn't make any sense then
i started bringing so i'd bring like one
of those like little airplane bottles
you know what i mean and i'd be like
just one one little thing you know kind
of like the priest does before he gets
up and gives a sermon
you guys didn't have priests like that
um
and it worked it worked it would be like
you'd get a little loosey-goosey you
know what i mean and i remember for this
one this one uh that i did this happened
actually a couple times i'm not gonna
lie where like i didn't have the
airplane but so i like just kind of
poured it into a like a container and
then brought it to the audition and then
i would you know just you know right
before the thing and then there were you
know a couple of occasions where i was
like oh sh and i'd be like oh that was
nope that was not one shot that was like
two or three
and uh you know and i remember uh one of
those things that i was up for at that
time i
they called me in and i'd just been
sitting there kind of looking at my
lines and when i stood up to go into the
audition i was like oh
okey dokey uh [ __ ]
and then i nailed it
[Laughter]
i absolutely [ __ ] nailed it and they
wanted me to do the show but i said no
i've got my own
just like that
um
but now luckily i'm i'm comfortable with
myself and i don't i don't have to i
don't feel the need to do that anymore
in auditions
have you been drinking today
uh no i haven't no i'll probably start
at like
3 30 for
great wow
it's my day off you know i mean i'm
gonna get it on
okay not worried about puffing up for
the picture
all the better all the better
you want to be a puffy guy you're
counting on it you're counting on the
puff
you know he's uh i'm playing
a guy's little bit of a miserable [ __ ]
in some ways so uh
for sure well it's great because i you
know i show up to set every day cranky
and i'm like well that's great because
this guy's cranky too so
here we are you know
just lean into the crankiness just a
little bit more than i already feel and
you know the anger all that's it's all
there it's all there
um anyways uh did you guys never do the
the whole like have a little shot shotty
poo before going into audition yeah i i
remember uh
auditioning to get into the williamstown
theater festival and um
i took the bus into new york city i was
still in college and was like so nervous
uh before the audition just so nervous
you know and uh
just being like i just went across the
street just had like a beer maybe i'll
probably only have one
and
just take the edge off yeah exactly it
helps for sure and that's why that's why
i didn't get any of those jobs that's
why it's not because i wasn't yeah
because i was too sober that was the
problem square man
drinking if i was drinking anything from
paul schrader and he should have been
like so you gotta get all [ __ ] up and
write your
thing haven't you learned anything he
in case what like he gets mad at his
computer and he wants to shoot it like
what the [ __ ] does he have i didn't ask
i don't i didn't ask i just noticed it i
clocked it i recognized that it was in
the room and i let it it was like a
souvenir from like taxi driver was it
like one of like travis pickles guns
could have been it wasn't displayed
in any way it was just sort of rest it
was in resting mode sort of a just sort
of an implied gentle threat to whoever
comes into the room you know what i mean
like it's sort of a power dynamic thing
right although i found him to be lovely
i mean he was she was strange he could
be he had a gun on his desk
he was very he was very kind and
courteous and
and and he was i
but it was ultimately it was not a great
experience but not because of our
interactions in any way and uh the gun
never never came into play
maybe it was like a check off thing
isn't that like a chekhov thing i don't
know you you theater nerds
well but that's the no the check off
thing is if you're going to show a gun
then it's got to be it better go off got
it it needs to go off at some point
otherwise what was the [ __ ] point so
that that was checked i see that gun
yeah exactly
we saw a lot of guns in this episode and
none of them went off um not to bring it
back to the episode but that was uh that
was
but it is very funny that you all end up
with guns at the uh at the end
at least uh charlie and dee i think end
up with guns and frank's always got one
and yeah now it's great that it's like
it's kind of like oh that was uh
that was close it was a close call
yeah
and then we ran that horse down uh yeah
yeah broad street yeah what was that
what was it what street
street was it broad street right it's
either broad street it might have been
market actually it may have been market
structure i think it was it was major i
think it was market it was market
to remember it was market street did you
get to walk off the street for that did
you get to shut down the streets yeah it
was like our
biggest thing we'd done at the time
which was like we shut down a big sort
of street and we ran a horse down it and
what a waste of money god that's fine
we barely use it in the episode
you know it's a tag it's a tag which we
don't exactly was it it wasn't meant to
be like we wouldn't have put aside all
that money and time and effort to just
shoot a tag that must have been
something that we decided in post right
like
just well i mean how else would it have
played i think we knew it was going to
be a tag didn't we
yeah good for us good for us
guys
um guess what yeah we're going to do a
second advertisement you know because
everyone loves them so much so we're
going together okay yeah all right well
ladies and gentle creeps we are
supported
by athletic greens yep the makers of
ag-1 green powder a product y'all know i
use literally every single day
i started taking ag-1 because i didn't
want to waste time rounding up dozens
and dozens of vitamins on the daily okay
i wanted it all in one
simple
silver bullet of a supplement correct
and with one delicious scoop of ag1
you're getting 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole foods source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens
it's lifestyle and diet friendly whether
you eat animals plants or rocks
it's certified keto paleo vegan dairy
free and gluten-free
it's also gmo free doesn't have any
nasty chemicals or seven-syllable
compounds from a lab and there's less
than one gram of sugar there's
legitimately more sugar in a lemon than
in a serving of ag-1 mm-hmm yeah can i
tell you guys something
i like ag-1 so much
that i brought it all the way to canada
i've already had i've already had mine
today by the way that's why it's it's
empty but uh yeah i got it i brought it
all the way to canada this guy you know
keep me fueled how those adaptogens
doing you uh
good i've adapted for the most part to
to being here um you know and and so so
you're a member of the bottle carrying
club there uh are you more of a fan of
the powder or the bottle
yeah no the i mean the powder itself is
an absolute a plus but uh the bottle's
not too shabby either i mean you can you
can you can creep on the size here look
at this it's actually perfectly
proportioned to the amount of ag-1 that
you need each day and it's it's smaller
than most shake bottles so you can
easily stow it or fly with it between
countries you know so that sounds like
the ultimate travel companion is that is
that what we're saying here well um i'll
tell you what it does work to support
better sleep quality and recovery which
honestly is a paramount when you're out
of town or changing time zones uh we
can't say paramount glenn because our
show's on disney
okay
to make it easy athletic reads is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com sunny again that is
athleticgreens.com
sunny to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
[Music]
peter ninka pope how'd you come up with
an income name peter
poop
um what a funny word
when i moved to los angeles um
i moved into an apartment
in the valley
and when we moved in there was a
refrigerator there and the p the
previous tenants had left they they
didn't take all of their possessions
with them and the landlord didn't even
bother to take it out
and on the refrigerator there was a
drawing of a horse
by a child with a magnet on it and it
was and all it said was
synchro
scaly face
was the name of the horse
and i remember thinking that is bizarre
what's the story
behind this it's a child
who came up with the name and then
spelled out synchro
scalyface
and um i remember being in the writer's
room and pitching that as as the name of
the horse and everybody was very
confused but then recognized that coming
up with a funny name for it would work
and somebody threw out peter
and then we added an incompoop and that
was it
it's better than synchro scalyface for
sure
absolutely
exactly sort
why was the horse
why did the horse have scales i don't
know maybe was it maybe it wasn't
it was this david sure david
cronenberg's uh
kid
you know what i mean was david
cronenberg living in that apartment for
a short period of time in l.a
it just seems like something he would
come up with i don't know
nincompoop i tried to look up the
origins of that word um last night
because i was like where the hell did
that word come from it's unclear
unclear uh a couple of explanations as
to where the nincom part comes from but
where the poop comes in i have no idea
so i think it's just
i think it's just uh absolute gibberish
but uh it's it's it's lovely
it's kind of gibberish
it's good gibberish
yeah cocaine
i was thinking of
of episode ideas maybe we could discuss
them now and and and the
the creeps the listeners could could
weigh in on on which ones they might
want to see
um
well you've got some ideas
i was going to pitch a couple of ideas
to you
what do you think
um yeah you don't you don't even want to
hear the idea i sure do but yeah sure so
what we've been talking about having mr
david hornsby in on the show and maybe
finding the best episode but i know the
cricket cricket's tale isn't for so long
and david's been these are pitches for
podcast episodes i thought yeah sunday
oh i think no no podcast i think you're
talking about sunday episodes too okay
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry it's okay
my mind's all about the podcast right
okay that's great so if we did a david
hornsby episode it might be fun to to to
cut together a cricket's greatest hits
and we could watch oh you're already
doing that yes megan's already at mark
megan's already well as soon as i get
access to 15 seasons of high def
versions of the episodes which i'm
working on now but yeah we're great
maybe we could do a watch party with
david and talk about each okay meg's
already got meg's already
we're in sync i was thinking um it might
be fun
i launched um
as you guys are aware i i launched a uh
a tech entertainment company today and i
and i i tweeted it out and it's just
getting a lot of expected hate and it's
really it's really kind of fun
and it made me think man we've gotten a
lot of
we've got we've gotten hate over the
over the years we've got our trolls
wouldn't it be fun
to maybe
i don't know that like just reading the
tweets is that fun but
taking calls of criticism the idea of
opening up the lines and letting people
know that i love it
yeah call in and and tell us directly
like what's what are we doing let us
have it
yeah yeah really let us have it and they
have to and besides hiring women oh
hiring women i want to hear about
somebody getting very upset about hiring
women we got badgers into it they don't
like it
you're saying i have a platform for
people to air their grievances
yes but directly to us at us and for us
we can do that
for me personally i have no boundaries
if they want to get per as personal as
possible they can i i feel i feel uh
comfortable having engaging in those in
those conversations i
meg and i had a version of this before
that we had talked about um about
actually a whole podcast that revolved
around it um but
bringing on various creators and having
people call in and talk about how they
hated their shows or if they loved their
shows where they went off the rails i
think that's what i'd be most interested
in meg and i may have made a pilot of
this
we call it thanks for engaging and it
was with damon lindelof and it was
[ __ ]
amazing it was amazing she tracked down
she and mara tracked down this was like
a year ago tracked down people who just
absolutely hated
like loved lost but hated the ending or
just hated watchmen and they just
hammered him and they did the same for
uh for for us
for me for sonny but it didn't have the
same sting
yeah and ultimately
the way any show ends like when a show
ends it's naturally unsatisfying right
because you're mad
you're mad yeah yeah like the sopranos
people hated that ending and seinfeld
people hate yeah
yeah
i see i think people like the ending of
the shield
i think people enjoyed that the way that
was a great ending i mean but
breaking bad is a great example of a
show that ended really well but
but still
you're left with
almost nothing to talk about and in a
way the sopranos for as unsatisfying as
it is
continues to live on because you can
talk about what your idea of what
happened in the end is that's just an
interest i like that also like some
shows are really built and designed to
have a beginning middle and end right
like um versus like an episodic show
like ours
it's a different thing than like a movie
where it really has like three acts
right like it's well breaking bad
totally like you don't see in the
sopranos the first episode isn't him
becoming tony soprano he just is tony
soprano who's going about his day
whereas breaking bad you watch as he
becomes walter white goes from a teacher
to
to to scarface basically and that's what
you're watching so there is a natural
end point and what they do five seasons
of that
something like that five or six six
six
breaking bad you mean
yeah yeah but if it's like a mystery
show then you solve the mystery and then
you're done but yeah like sunny is
especially gonna be hard for you guys to
end because there's not even that much
that rolls from episode to episode so
it's not really building to anything
like in a way that like even breaking
brad
breaking bad
that's mythic quest episode somebody's
definitely going to make a show called
breaking brad
glenn we've already done it
we have a show called
the criticism call-in episode we should
definitely do that we can have that
happen people call and yell at you guys
about stuff
yeah and it could be about anything it
could be about it should be about sunny
because that's what the podcast is but i
don't know come out come at us it could
be fun let's do it
gloves
when you do that if people sort of like
quickly drum up uh sort of fake thing
versus like getting someone who really
has something to say to be like you know
i really love when you did this and you
stopped doing this and why did you do it
versus someone who's like okay i got to
think of something to criticize and then
just like coming up with the what's we
just hang up on those people immediately
just hang up on them immediately there
was a curation process that went into it
that worked pretty well that megan
marrow found really great people they
were able to but
but
to to allow for that to not happen
my my favorite was that i found some
tweets that people had tweeted about
like sunny and one of my favorite one
was
is the dick really worth the three hours
of always sunny he makes you watch
afterwards
[Laughter]
the answer is yes
which is pretty good she was really not
into the show at all but she was into
the dick but there was a guy the guy
that we talked to was from he he was
irish and he was calling from ireland
he's a massive son
yeah but he was like he was begging us
to stop
begging us to stop he said we ruined the
show a long time ago stop making it
we've we've peaked we've we've not only
have we begun to peak we peaked it's
over please stop just please stop and it
was that's such a funny thing it's like
well you have sir you have you have
total control over that go ahead and
don't don't watch the show can end yes
right now for you like just stop
watching he believes that we were we're
ruining the legacy of the show
by continuing to exist which i thought
was a great point of view he had great
points he wasn't he wasn't yeah no it's
wrong from his point of view he pitched
an end that wasn't terrible like
remember that he he pitched an end we
were like okay what it was yeah don't
say it though because we might use it
but we're never going to end this show
not officially
you